Doco. I struggle with receiving
banter from other guys. Banter. Okay.
I'm naturally a sensitive gut which lends
myself to take normal smack talk from
other guys. Personally, I'm trying to get
after it. I wake up early, I work out,
eat healthy,
work pretty hard,
but still seem to have some deep seeded
insecurities which flare up when guys
give me stick,
I have some bloody good mates.
Okay.
Yeah,
and I want to get to the point where I
can take smack talk for what it is and
even give a bit of stick back to the guys.
What can I do to help this?
Here's one thing that you can try to
get into your brain and this is one of
those things that's hard to get into your
brain and it's even harder to actually
get it in your brain and functionally
use this thought. Here's the thought.
The more, okay? If you're, if
you're paranoid about something,
if you're insecure about something,
the more you let things bother you,
the more insecure you will appear.
Well,
let me say that again.
The more you let things bother you,
the more insecure you are going to appear.
And the worst,
whatever that thing that
you're worried about,
makes you feel insecure,
the worst it's going to
appear to everyone else.
So if you got a big nose and you're
embarrassed because you got a big nose and
every time someone says
something about your big nose,
you get mad and you get offended,
that big nose it be even bigger.
So think about that.
If there's something that bothers
you and you let it be known,
yeah
and you let it bother you,
divorce, it's going to get.
And also think about this.
Another thing that will help,
these are things I'm
trying to help help uh,
sort of smooth the edges of
insecurity. Here's another one. People,
even though you think
evenly think they are,
and it's kind of egotistical to
think this, but we all do it.
People aren't sitting around and
thinking about you and your weaknesses.
They're not sitting around and
They're not like, that's
your ego telling you that. So
don't sit there and think everyone is
looking at your big nose all the time.
They don't care.
They've got their other problems.
They've got their own life going on.
You don't care about your big nose wheel.
You know what makes them care about it?
When they know, if they say something you,
it bothers you.
That's the first thing you're gonna
think when they see you again.
Here comes the good time. Some fun.
Yeah. And here's another thing.
If you want to kind of mitigate that man,
do want to do it.
Mark doesn't weigh the warrior
kid when Uncle Jake says, hey,
if you're getting made fun of is in way
the word could call them plate face.
Yeah. Saint Marco, you got to route
this guy. Nathan James had Telemaco.
You've got round face.
You look like plate calls him plate face.
That's his insult.
As insults him all the time.
And it bothers him cause he's looking
in the mirror going, right, I do.
I look like a plane. Let it bother
him. And Uncle Jake says, hey, go,
go make fun of yourself. And he finally
gets a chance. He does. Uh, they're,
you know,
a class and they have to do a self
portrait and he draws himself as a plate,
a plate face.
And when the kid that's been making fun
of it sees and he laughs and then guess
what doesn't make fun of him anymore
about it because he realizes it doesn't
bother and they kind of bond a little bit.
Then they kind of modeled what he's going
for in this question. That is, yeah.
Yeah. So you got, um,
and it's, it's this what,
that's why I said it's hard to do this
because when you're insecure about your
big nose or you're insecure about your
big ears or whenever and you let people
know that, or B, you just
think it's in your brain. You
think if you say something,
let's get even more so
they won't get worse.
It might get worse for an uptick
for a second, right? It might,
you make fun of yourself, you know,
people like, oh yeah, that's right.
I didn't notice that you do it. Then
it'll kind of, no one really cares.
And that's why in the teams and the teams,
you never let anyone know that something
bothers you or if they know it bothers
you, you're going to hear about it
forever. That's just going to be how,
it's just the way it's going to be.
And what that means.
The polar opposite of that or the flip
side of that is it's not fun to harass
some, it's not fun to harass someone
about something that doesn't bother them.
It's not even fun. Right. It's not
fun. Why would you harass them?
One when they don't get it,
when you don't even get a rise out of him,
this is not fun. You just leave that thing
that you look for something else. Yeah.
So poke a little fun at yourself.
These guys are going to back
off because they're bored.
If you show no reaction and like you
said that that kind of self deprecating
humor will formed a little bond.
Yeah.
You can give a little stick back to
the guys. If you start giving stick.
The guys be ready to take it back though.
Yeah, they're going to escalate. Yeah.
And that's just so, I mean,
I grew up with two brothers.
Oh one twin brother.
And that's like a,
like that's literally the foundation of
our relationship is just you tease the
other guy about some lit everything.
Like he can come in with a new shirt on
that's a seal platoon. Yeah. Like, oh,
we'll be like, oh no sure.
No, you know like Beth,
not even something to tease someone.
They sell men's shirts where you bought
that. Yeah, whatever. It's literally,
it's so bad to the point
where one, um, when,
when I got with my current life, when we
were, when we started dating or whatever,
like it's just habit, you know? And like
even you like, same thing, you know,
like you'll, you'll give me crap,
I'll give you criminal, whatever.
But it's so common that I
do it to her. Oh yeah. Yeah.
And you know, at first she's
like, Oh, what? Like what,
why are you teasing me so much like your,
cause I knew where he'd been
before we were together.
I knew her for years actually. And he's
like, Hey, I kind of annoying, you know,
you'd like teases or whatever.
And I did like reel it back
yourself and yeah, because that,
because that is so, so much
of how guys do it, you know,
to 100% and I've told this
story before when I got,
when I was going to college and I was
around team guys all day and I started
doing the team guy thing with my
wife after she, she's like, Hey,
I'm not in the teams so you can
be quiet now. And I was like, wow,
she's right. And I didn't even realize
it cause that's just, you know,
all day long you show up,
you show up in the platoon
space and his verbal sparring.
As soon as you walk through the door,
somebody is going to say something,
they're going to bring it. And what's
interesting is Holly, how he's like,
I want to get to the point where, you
know, he can say back to her with things,
I would agree with this.
I'll probably even hundred 10% which is
hard to agree 100% but I feel this way
probably stronger than him.
Like you ever been around someone who
like you just can't really joke around
with like,
I'm not,
I'm not the kind guy who all tease
someone and try to like to make them,
you know, especially if I don't
know him good or whatever. But um,
but if you're around someone who like,
can't really take it,
you can't joke around with
them. It's like, man, I don't
want that guy to be there,
man. I wish he just wasn't, you
know, I'm not mad at him, but I just,
I don't want to hang around with that guy.
You don't want to be that guy.
So even if like, like, especially
at first, like let's say, okay, I'm,
I'm this guy right here.
The worst is someone that can dish
it out but can't take it. Yeah.
But what do you mean? Yeah, that
is the worst. It's, I, I wouldn't,
the only reason I wouldn't say he's
the worst is what's worse than that.
If he's dishing it out
and he can't take it,
it's kind of you get a pay
off of teasing the guy.
I'm just saying it lists that he doesn't
do shit up. Let's say he's just a guy,
you just can't joke around with it.
It's like man,
you're making me uncomfortable
kind of thing, you know.
But if this guy cause you to your point,
if it's yeah,
if the load is annoying when people can't
take it and you make a joke and they
get all fired up and then they're like
actually mad, right? Yeah, that's,
that's what, that's how you end up with
people that aren't really your friends.
Maybe your friends. Exactly. Right.
So, but yes. Yes. So you get there men.
I say get there and at first just,
and you kind of made it
really clear to me how,
you know when you make a change or
something, it's not going to whoop boom,
you're off to the races with the change
going full speed. You know, what'd he say?
Low drag. When weight load hospital, it's
not going to be like they're ready for,
especially with this kind of stuff. If
you, if you already know you're insecure.
Yeah. Which is a big
step ahead, by the way.
Some people do it or I'm not an insecure,
and meanwhile they're, he's curating it.
They know it, but they just don't admit
it. Yeah. So this guy, he knows so,
but you're going to feel it, man,
when they call you big, you know,
whatever they're calling you,
whatever,
you're going to sort of feel it on the
inside still, but just don't behave,
you know, in a way, just be like,
Oh, I dunno. I don't know what to do.
There's plenty of things
to do, but know, I mean,
you do want to get their
hundred percent check.